[Musik]
hast du das gerade gehört hast denn was
denn dass die schärfe mich gerade
beschimpft hat folgen anderen kollegen
obwohl ich manchmal fehler mache kann
sie so nicht mit mir sprechen möchte
es war respektlos aber du hast dich hier
setzt aber auf ich sage ich akzeptieren
dass das länger was fällt er eigentlich
ein okay sie ist meine chefin
trotzdem kann sie doch nur mal mit mir
sprechen mit herrn müller hat es solche
probleme nie gegeben obwohl er der chef
war aber diese frauen na ja was denn
sonst männer gehen arbeiten frauen
machen den haushalt dafür gibt es gute
gründe
dann macht jeder was er am besten kann
jetzt mal langsam
ich sehe das ganz anders meine doch das
wäre nur arbeitet und studiert
und ich will sich sonst sehe ich rede ja
gar nicht von seiner tochter denn die
habe ich ja gar nix aber so eine
situation die gerade wer mit dem letzten
chef nicht passiert der war total anders
die tränen
wie bereit
ja ja ich brauche keinen krankenwagen
kollege von mir ich weiß nicht